[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
hello and welcome to tactics time i am
nick risco
one of the instructors here at the st
louis chess club and i'm filling in for
caleb denby tonight as he is on vacation
he will be returning soon for tactics
time and openings explained
we just finished up openings explained
on youtube so go check that out
but here we're going to focus on tactics
and we're going to talk about
interesting topic we're going to talk
about how computers
suck at chess tonight we have a
collection of puzzles that
even the strongest computers cannot
evaluate correctly
we're going to go through those and also
talk about why computers can't solve
them
first just to warm everybody up we're
actually going to start with just a mate
and one puzzle which a computer can
solve
and then move on from there this may be
probably
one of the most ridiculous puzzles we
have ever had here on tactics time
but we'll pull that up for you guys here
i'm not going to tell you guys which
side to move
but which move and which side to move is
going to be mate in one
we're going to leave it up until we have
an answer in the chat
hmm
looks like i'm having issues connecting
to the chat
oops i broke it um if it is white to
move
it's possible it's mating too but again
just in case chat doesn't know um
i'm not going to tell you which side to
move i'm trying to warm everybody up
here i want you guys to find the mate
and one
for either side to move
so yes again this is a matin one
give it probably another 30 seconds
see if anybody else has any ideas
okay uh we're going to move on um so
here is actually um a matin one for
black so if it is black to move there's
a mate in one
we're going to look at the kings first i
will actually show white to move
the best you can do with white to move
is matin 2
and the way that this is accomplished is
with uh
pawn takes g8 or sorry
rather not pawn takes g8 uh
oh gosh everything is breaking
the best move here is uh
knight takes g8 and then after knight
takes g8
pawn takes and not turning into a queen
under promoting to a knight
so this is if it were white to move that
is the best you can do
with black to move there is only one
mate and one
and it has to do with this knight here
on a6 it's going to come down to b4
and you'll notice it's surrounded by a
bunch of other knights
no bishops so it cannot be captured will
deliver
checkmate to the king
okay enough silliness we're going to get
into real puzzles tonight
again like i said tonight's puzzles are
going to focus on why um
computers are bad at chess um
one of the problems with teaching a
tactics class is uh it's hard to prevent
people
from just plugging in the position to
their computer so
the theme for tonight is going to be
puzzles computers cannot solve
puzzles that computers just if you give
them enough time we'll never find
the correct solution so we're going to
start off with this first puzzle here
white to move and it's going to have to
be a white to move and draw
obviously with black being up so much
material the best white can do is draw
there are no mates
this puzzle here actually comes from a
penrose institute study
where they wanted to compare different
ways
humans solve puzzles see who finds the
right ideas
for some reason why the computers can't
find it
so even if we did have the computer
evaluation here
i'll give it to you guys right now
stockfish 12 on depth
59 is saying that this position is minus
19.9
but that's not going to help you these
are puzzles computers can't solve
so we'll give chat a few minutes to try
and come up with any ideas here of
how white is supposed to handle this
position
what are some of the features here what
are some of the candidate moves
do we even need to you know calculate
specific moves or is just a plan good
enough
great wolf is wondering why you can't
just shuffle the white king
just don't take anything so that is a
good idea
we'll touch on it again in just a second
while i'm giving the chat enough time to
try and gather their ideas i'm going to
talk a little bit about
why for this specific problem the
computer is not able to find
the right solution again i said on depth
59
the latest version of stockfish stock
fish 12 is uh
saying that this position is minus 19.9
and the reason that computers can't
solve this is
mainly because of these bishops with
just one bishop on the board
the computer will find the correct
evaluation almost immediately
with only two bishops on the board it's
going to take some extensive calculation
but eventually the computer is going to
find the correct solution
but with all three bishops here there
are
many many many possible candidate moves
here
and it's going to take a lot of computer
resources
to be able to calculate every single one
of these bishop moves
so one of the reasons why this specific
puzzle cannot be solved correctly
is because of the extensive resources it
needs for the computer
to evaluate all of these possible bishop
moves
it's um like distracting the computer
there's not enough focus
of the computer on what actually matters
for it to find the right
solution
so we have great wolf and i manny
working on this anybody else in the chat
have any ideas
and i think it should go without saying
that um
i believe none of these puzzles come
from real games
manny's suggesting the very practical
solution of just
running the clock out for black if this
were a real game
just play whatever moves because the
engine is going to be busy calculating
random moves
but yeah we're going to go back to great
wolf's suggestion
why can't you just shuffle the white
king and this is a very good question
this is actually um
in the results of the study they found
that while engines can never
find the solution most strong tournament
players are able to find the solution
instantly for those who saw it in the
chat great wolf
almost spit out the suggestion
immediately why don't you just shuffle
the king
if you take a look at it all of white's
pawns
are on light colored squares which means
that none of these bishops are able to
do anything to affect these pawns
also black has no legal moves with their
pawns
thanks to being obstructed by their own
pieces and our pawns
because of these pawns being stuck the
queen and the rooks
also have no legal moves and the king
has no legal move to escape because
pawns control one square diagonally
with black not being able to do anything
to affect our pawns which are creating
this barricade
we can actually just move the king
around without much calculation at all
we can actually just make any king moves
as long as they're on the light squares
we don't need to worry about anything
there's no way for black to break
through this barricade
so these pieces are going to be stuck
forever and the dinosaur bishops are
going to be moving around forever
there are a couple things that um white
needs to watch out for while they play
they don't want to be pushing their
pieces around
for example if white plays pawn to c7
this is going to be
a this is going to be a loss for white
uh almost immediately black can just
take the pawn white is going to have to
make a move and now the king can escape
and once the king escapes they can step
out of the way for the queen to come
down so just some examples here
of the king moving around now the queen
escapes and this is going to be made in
no time for black
but as long as white doesn't push these
pawns and makes king moves they can draw
with ease
and in fact if the computer just like
short circuits we should say moves all
of the bishops off of the diagonal
then white can actually win this
position by pushing the pawn
of course this isn't really tricking the
computer into giving you a win this is
more of a more of a help
mate but as the first
first position of the night is uh this
puzzle from a study from the penrose
institute
you want that oh my god
okay i'm fixing it
ben is having a heart attack in our
studio right now
okay ben are we gonna be good to move on
okay ben says it's fine so we're gonna
move on to the next puzzle
um i believe this next puzzle here is a
puzzle from frederick friedel in a
chess-based article
where they gave this position to
computers
and people to try and find the solution
to again this is a puzzle that
some uh some good uh players can find
almost instantly
um but computers will never be able to
solve it
and yes manny this is a pyramid tactic
close cousin of the pyramid scheme
philidor is saying lock the game up um
very good suggestion there are many many
ways to try and do this
many many of them fail so i want you to
be a little bit more specific in your
answer
of how are we going to lock this game up
if you'll notice there are many many
many many pawn captures to consider
the many many pawn pushes to consider
there's a couple checks with the bishop
to consider
so lots of moves here
and great wolf again coming here with
the solution
bishop to a4 check then check all the
way down then
f5 draw so great wolf is just on fire
tonight um obviously great tactician
not using computers because computers
can't solve these
um just so you guys know the computer
evaluation of this position
using stockfish 12 on depth 24
stockfish says that this position is
minus 9.6
and actually never even comes to the
conclusion that the end position is a
draw
so here bishop to a4 check
the only move here is king takes
a4 if king to c4
oh no i can't even use the computer to
help me
bishop to b3 after king to b5 then c4
and check all the way down
um but the main move is king takes a4
and just like great wolf said you check
all the way down
it's very important these are checks as
well because if you ever allow black to
capture one of these pawns
white is going to be in serious trouble
because they are going to be down
two rooks
so we check all the way down now here if
black
doesn't capture the bishop we just play
f5
and if they capture we have this very
interesting situation
where philidor was talking about how we
need to lock up the game and now the
pawns block
all the entrances into white's half of
the board
and with these rooks there is no way to
break through
if a rook ever puts itself on a square
like a3
white never should take this rook it
will create a breakthrough position
instead of taking the rook white is just
going to shuffle the king around in a
square
ignoring the fact that black is hanging
rooks
and just move around on their side for
50 moves
and for those of you who don't know 50
move rule is whenever there are no
captures or pawn pushes for 50 moves the
game is a draw
in the scenario where black takes the
bishop again
just f5 and there's
nothing here let's say black completely
avoids
taking the bishop we still play f5 if
they play a rook move
we can take their bishop they take our
bishop and again we have two rooks that
will never be able to break through
this uh pawn pawn chain
this kind of idea is something that
hikaru nakamura used in his battles i
believe against the computer
komodo uh it may have been against
houdini i can't remember which engine it
was
exactly this was a long time ago
nakamura played against the engine
and had a double exchange sacrifice
because the rooks are not able to break
through locked up positions like this
so actually having the two minor pieces
for the two rooks
was good enough to win the position
uh i'm annie is saying that this uh
structure with the pawns
is known as the iron curtain uh
wondering if it's known like that in
english
i believe it is um although i'm not a
100 sure on the technical term
for this kind of setup
okay we are just flying through these
puzzles
okay this next one is um a puzzle that
its origins are a little mysterious it's
a little bit
back and forth on where this puzzle
comes from
uh this puzzle uh i guess the most
famous one
uh is that it was shown at um i think it
was the arko
tournament of 1979
maybe maybe 1978. um but there was a
tournament there
or sorry avro not arco uh avro
tournament where it had like kasparov
bence larson
tal someone showed up showed them
this puzzle in between games tao looked
at it for 10 minutes walked away for an
hour
and when he came back the magician had
solved the puzzle
this is another puzzle that the computer
cannot solve this one is also
very
very famous so if you do know the
solution
good to you i want to make sure that
other people have enough time to
to try and figure out this puzzle this
one is definitely more
complicated than just white to move and
draw this one is actually a white to
move and win
and again i will give you guys the
computer evaluation because i know it
won't help
stockfish 12 on depth 41 says this
position is minus two and a half
which means black is uh better by almost
a full minor piece
this one is white to move and win
not white to move and draw
so i'll give the chats um you know 30
seconds to a minute to try and get their
thoughts together
try and uh make it through and then we
will
start talking about all the different
variations
manny says that he's seen this one it's
about 10 moves
uh yeah it's about 11 moves um 12 moves
for
i guess if you take the longest solution
it's like 13 moves but the the main idea
is 11 moves
we'll give another 15 seconds here
okay so we're not going to go through
the
the solution just yet we're going to
talk about some of the features in the
position
and why some may or may not work right
away
so the very first candidate move that
any player might consider
is pawn push and promote to queen
and the reason for this is just to be
able to uh
to get your material back and if white
can get a queen they should be doing
well they should be able to win this
game
it's going to take a while but white
should win
uh and many you are correct the uh the
engine does realize
their loss after you know about seven or
eight moves it does take it a while
to be able to realize it's losing um
but back to this first candidate move
pawn to d8 queen
the problem with this move right away is
that black has this annoying little
check knight f7
where after the king moves and the
knight takes the king takes
here you have a position where black is
just three pawns up
and it's going to be very very difficult
for white to even draw this black should
just be winning here
so unfortunately pawn to d8 immediately
does not work
so we need to think of other candidate
moves
are there any suggestions from the chat
does anybody think they have it
i am noticing it's a lot longer for the
answers to be coming in tonight
i guess we don't have our 2800 viewers
2800 level viewers who are solving the
tactics
instantly
i'm not seeing any suggestions coming so
we'll start going over the solution
starting with the first move
oh someone is saying go to d8 and
promote to a knight
okay philidor says d8 knight
very nice suggestion but here
uh let's see i think pawn to c4
is one of the recommendations coming
with check after king to c6
even without this check black should
have pawn to e2
and if the bishop takes then
it looks like pawn to c4 check this is
to make sure the knight isn't taken by
the bishop
after king to c6 pawn to c2
this pawn is going to queen so
unfortunately knight to
d8 and promoting to a sorry pawn to d8
and promoting to a knight
also isn't going to work unfortunately
it just seems like black has everything
covered
it's almost like this position feels
like it's minus two and a half
but we know better the first move here
is knight to f6 check and just like any
tactic
or really any move in a chess game you
want to make sure
you're considering your your forcing
moves in your candidate moves so the
level of forcing moves
you have checks you have captures and
you have threats to capture
so we should always look at our checks
for our first candidate moves
so now that we have this check it
actually forces black's response
the only response to a night check is to
either take the knight or move the king
nothing can take the knight so the king
has to move so now we need to decide
what is the best square for our king
here
so let's start with king to h8 and why
king to h8 doesn't work
leave it to the chat to find these
little solutions
king to h8 why doesn't it work
we have jay holden and great wolf
and manny all saying promote to queen
and yes
so before this did not work because
knight f7 would fork the king and queen
but here with the king on h8
this is actually delivered with check so
no knight f7 after black has to respond
to this check only move is king g7 and
now the queen can move out of the way
to safety there are many like
quick mates here there's like a mate and
three after knight h5 but
to keep it practical to keep it simple
so you guys can remember
some of these techniques in your own
games um you know if you can just save
the queen
and be up material you know you have a
winning position
that that is good enough reasoning um no
need to try and
uh kill yourself to find the fastest
mate
if you're looking for a refutation to a
move
the next best move is king to g6
and here after king to g6 the computer
uh
does realize that it's losing after this
move
now uh it will go back half a move here
on the knight check the position is
minus 6.3
after king to g6 the position is
plus 65.
so the engine is waking up after this
move
how do we refute king to g6
manny says he won't spoil anything
we might have to rely on great wolf
again
maybe bishop to c2
it's a good thought good thought so
bishop to c2 is a check
remember you always want to look at your
checks
and philly door is saying bishop to h5
let's see so great with n philly door
kind of have the same idea you want to
check with the bishop
the line that i have in my study is
bishop to h5 track we'll take a look at
bishop to c2 in just
a second the idea after a bishop to
h5 is that after king to f6
you can promote to a queen and it comes
with check so
no knight f7 if the king goes to
let's say f5 you can still promote to a
queen
because now after knight f7 the bishop
controls
f7 so
uh let's see uh cyclists
knows this position it's the one tao
solved after a smoke and a walk
yes that is the the most popular
origin story of this puzzle um
it is debated and the the real um
coming about of this puzzle was that it
was solved not solved
it was published about five years after
that tournament where
people were confused how was it
published after people knew it and what
happened was the composer actually um
just showed it around to a couple of his
friends who were on the tournament
circuit
and they thought it was really nice they
passed it around to their competitors
when they were at tournaments
like the avro tournament and uh yeah
the tile smoke break is the probably the
most famous origin story
of this puzzle uh let's see
back to this position we'll take a look
at bishop c2 and how that wins
if king to f6 again they just promote
with check
so we'll look at king to f7 if king to
f7
you can promote because what happens is
the king blocks the square for the
knight
so here we can look at king to g7 making
sure we don't block this square
and here it looks like there is a little
i guess this is like a only move for
white
with the bishop to h5 line it was pretty
clear because the f7 square was always
covered
here you can't promote to a queen right
away you have to make sure you play
another
move first so i'll give you guys just a
couple seconds
to find the move here
great wolf with knight h5 cyclist
saying king to e7 so
let's start with king to e7
um we'll start with king to e7 and
unfortunately this doesn't work
um mainly because a pawn to c4 and this
comes with check
the king has to go to e8 and here the
knight can go to
c7 check king d8 and the king blocks
his own pawn and now here
there are a couple moves but the most
straightforward is pawn to e2
and it's impossible to stop this pawn
from queening
so king to e7 doesn't work you have to
be more
forceful so great wolf's suggestion of
knight h5
is very clever uh the king cannot go to
f6
it's controlled by the knight it cannot
go to g6 it's controlled by the bishop
cannot go to h7 controlled by the bishop
so the king has to go to either the
eighth rank
or it has to go to f7 when the knight
goes
sorry when the king goes to f7 it blocks
the square for the night so we can
promote without fear
and if he goes to the eighth rank we
promote with check
promote without fear so knight h5
is the uh the move here forces the king
to a bad square
let's see um so let's see after
that uh that does refute king to g6
so now we have to go back to the main
line uh
after the very first move knight f6
check
black should play king to g7
and here the computer still thinks black
is winning here on depth
25 stock fish 12 says the position is
minus 5.1
yes uh manny is correct this was just
the beginning that was just move one
so one of the things that um can be
helpful when you're solving
any tactics or even just in your own
games it doesn't have to be tactical it
can also rely on positional plans
is if you calculate other lines that
don't get played
those ideas still may come into play
later in the future so we saw this
knight to h5
check idea in the bishop to c2 line
we know that we want to calculate our
forcing moves first and knight h5
is still a check here so we want to make
sure we can calculate
that out it's a very good starting point
because it was a theme
in our other lines so it should be it
should be easier to calculate
knight h5 check and king to g6
is practically the only move again if it
goes to f7 we can promote without fear
because the knight is blocked
and if it goes to the eighth rank we
promote with check so king to g6 is
forced
and we have this new position king is on
g6
white is still trying to promote knight
still controls f7 what do we do
what do we do in this crazy position
and now even though we've gone further
down the solution the computer
thinks it's even better than it was
before a computer is now saying that at
depth 27 the position is minus 6.8
bishop to b3 is a suggestion
so if we go bishop to b3 what are you
going to do
against c4 check so this is one of the
ideas we had earlier
like with the king to e7 line but the
problem was c4 check and the king had to
block their own pawn
after bishop to b3 c4 comes with check
the king has to move
um it's very difficult to find even a
legal move so let's say king to c6
um here we we can't
just uh i guess black can't just allow
white to promote so they have to stop
the promotion
and uh here looks fine for black
it's gonna be difficult for white to
stop both both of these pawns mainly the
e pawn from coming down and promoting
so unfortunately bishop b3 is not
forcing enough
there's someone suggesting knight f4
let's see after knight f4
king f5 what's your follow-up
trying to figure out what what the plan
is here for whites because as it stands
currently
the black knight still controls f7 which
will
fork the king and queen
bishop h5 here if bishop h5
black just has pawn to c2 sorry
actually not pawn to c2 it looks like
it's really hard to refute lines in a
puzzle which computers don't understand
so forgive me if i'm a little slow to
find
the best move here looks like knight to
e4
check the king has to move uh if he
comes to
d yeah e7 we run into
the c4 check again after the king moves
down
knight f6 just picks up the pawn and
then this bishop
is not able to stop both of these pawns
uh mainly the c
pawn so i i hope that's a good enough
refutation for you
with uh knight to f4 and if you go
bishop to h5 again
it looks like the knight check or
the pawn check are going to help black
win and promote this c
pawn now i agree philly door
chest is hard
so i am not a believer in knight to f4
although very good try because we do
want to make sure we are calculating
our forcing moves first
bishop c2 check question mark
in the chat bishop to c2 check
and i will let you know the engine does
change its analysis on this move
bishop to c2 check we have to look at
what black's best move is
they can't go to g7 or f6 or h7 because
they're controlled by
blacks you know sorry by blacks
sorry white's pieces if the king goes to
f7 we can promote without fear because
it blocks the knights square to fork
and then he's saying i am homeless on
wifi saying this puzzle is incorrect due
to a secondary solution
i don't believe there is a secondary
solution in the main line
let me double check my study here
yeah no there is no second solution in
the main line
that was one of the uh one of the
sidelines that we were looking
at
so um here the king
should take on h5 and now the computer's
starting to understand what's going on
it still doesn't understand the entire
thing but it does say now that the
position is plus
3.8
um so let's see let's keep going
next move here for white i'm going to
let you guys find it
this is a bit of a tougher move to find
i think to be able to find this move and
the idea behind it you're gonna have to
like solve the rest of the puzzle
cyprus has the right idea black's king
is getting trapped and he takes the
knight
the progress is suggesting king to e7
uh so let's take a look at king to e7
real quick
i believe well let's try c4 because this
has been like the the refutation of most
of the lines so pawn to c4
if king to f6 then
it looks like there's some weird
bishop e7 check king e7 and pawn to e2
is going to be your refutation
yes you can promote but black is going
to promote with check and then be able
to trade off
queens and then black is going to be up
a night in two pawns
and uh just so you know like the plan
here uh for that knight and two pawns on
the game it's not going to be an easy
draw
even though it looks like these pawns
are isolated and the bishop stops it
uh there's no way that white can save
this g-pawn
black is just going to pile up with the
king and knight and take this pawn for
free
and then the bishop is not going to be
able to stop the c-pawn
and the h pawn
so king takes the knight
philidor is starting to try and plan out
what needs to happen in the rest of the
game so if we wanted to mate with
just the pieces we have on the board we
want our king to be on
f5 and we want our bishop to be
on the d1 to h5 diagonal to mate
so very good plan now philidor the
challenge is how do you make it happen
how can you make your plan come to life
i have a suggestion so maybe d8 queen
and let the knight take the queen
for tempo so yes this is a very good
idea
sacrificing your pawn for tempo
so we'll walk through it ideally you
would have this all calculated out
before you play the moves but
i want to make sure everybody is uh you
know everyone's on the same page
making sure that none of us are getting
lost trying to visualize
within the deep black hole of chess
so the idea is a queen and let them take
it
for tempo so king to e7
knight d8 and king f5 so we have the
first part of the plan
done we have the king on f5 we are ready
to put the bishop on d1
for mate however black has a move to
um i guess postpone this mate
so black plays pawn to e2
that way bishop to d1 is no longer
possible black will take
and promote to a queen and mate white
very shortly
so now how does white weasel their way
out of this one
the pawn on e2 is getting ready to
promote on a dark square
so it looks like they're just going to
get get away with
a free queen great wolf and quick
0 6 1 8 are saying bishop to e4
and this is correct um
cyclist is saying king e5 if bishop e2
then bishop e4
i'm not exactly sure what line that is
i'm having trouble
visualizing it um but great wolf and
quick
are correct bishop to e4
and the idea is that if queen then
bishop to f3 is checkmate
so black obviously cannot queen they
need to they need to stop
the checkmate so how do they do this how
do they stop it well
instead of promoting to a queen they
need to under promote to a knight
so the knight stops this check
i'm going to ask you guys where where
does white go now
yeah black never gives up yeah all you
guys thought it was over
all you guys thought this was going to
be checkmate
but uh truth be told we're only like
halfway through the puzzle
there's still more to go
bishop d5 now correct bishop d5
is the next move and there's a couple
ideas behind this
um but the main the main idea behind
bishop to d5
is to pass the bishop around the board
that way
it will be able to make it to a
different square on this diagonal
or maybe even on the e8 to h5 diagonal
to be able to
checkmate king so here the the threat
is bishop to b7
i believe let me make sure that's true
that is not true the bishop is trying to
go to c4
and checkmate on e2 my apologies
um so here pawn to c2
so again trying to go for promotion
and we will go bishop to c4
the bishop is hitting the knight and
threatening
going to e2 with mate and you guys
should see black's next move here
um black if they promote to a queen just
gets mated after
knight f3 and takes so they obviously
can't promote to a queen which means
the obvious night under promotion
i know you guys are loving this puzzle
so what does white do from here it seems
like all the squares are being covered
by knights
so yes black has four knights a bishop
and two pawns
against white's bishop and pawn and i'm
making the ridiculous crazy claim that
white is winning here
drunus is suggesting bishop to b5 go to
a4
and then d1 and i like this idea
going to b5 is actually kind of like a
fork between mating
mating ideas you have a bishop to e8
which is threatening mate along this
diagonal
and you have the idea of going to a4 and
d1 where it will be made along this
diagonal
so bishop to b5 so now you need to stop
the bishop coming to e8 so
again we will see a knight come to stop
the bishop from mating these knights are
just trying to control all the squares
that the bishop can go to
and then i guess jonas included in their
answer bishop goes to
a4 and here after bishop to a4
i'm going to say the puzzle is solved
and for those of you who don't see it
the reason why this is solved is there
is no way to control the d1 square
black cannot control the d1 square which
means that there's no way to stop the
checkmate
there's no way to check the white king
no way to take the pawn
and no way to like control a path
so that way after the check the piece
that is blocking can be defended
so no matter what black plays for
instance pawn to c4
then bishop to d1 knight e2
captures knight f3 captures is mate
so there is yet again another puzzle
that a computer cannot solve
and it looks like we still have some
time here so i will throw in
uh this last puzzle here
um let's see i am homeless is commenting
again on the previous puzzle so let's go
there
um they said the strongest engines
concluded there was no win
after four kingdom g4
so let's see
uh strong so let's see back to the
fourth move
d8 queen there's no win after king g4
so king g4
so we're actually in a position where
the computer kind of understands what's
happening
the computer catches up after bishop c2
um
but it would be a bit hypocritical for
me to use the computer to find the
refutation
but now that white has the queen it just
looks like it should be they have too
much
too much material um
let's see why can't they go queen f6
they're hitting the pawn and then
threatening
queen to f4
if c4 check probably king to d5
uh someone's suggesting e2 after the
queen move but after
e2 the queen can go to f4 check the king
has to go to h3
and now queen f2 you're on the pawn
so i think i think computers have
evolved enough to at least solve some of
these sidelines
obviously they have not evolved enough
to
to calculate the main line
on to the on to the final puzzle i don't
know if
how much thinking time we can give
but uh this is a puzzle from uh sorya
ganguly
i want to say 2017
gave it on their twitter and uh
they they said uh you know try and solve
this position and you're allowed to use
an engine
um the engine does give this a winning
evaluation for white
but i don't believe that the
the computer actually finds the correct
solution
so i'll give you guys a little bit of
time to try and figure out
this position definitely more difficult
than
any of the others definitely going to
have our longest solution the solution
for this one
is 31 moves long
i have faith in you guys
yes dronis this is uh where do we sack
the knight puzzle
king d2 for distant opposition
i like it unfortunately that's not going
to be our our solution here
um so first let's uh yeah let's take a
look at um
where where nights should go and where
any possible sacrifices can happen
the the main problem in this position is
it's almost like one of those um
dead chest positions so i believe if you
like look up the definition on
wikipedia is probably a good one um is
where the pawns are touching
each other in such a way that the
only moves that each side can make is
like shuffling their king on their own
side and there's no way to make
progress even though there's still
mating material
on the board so uh
here with the pawns locked up like this
neither king
can go to the other side of the board so
um we need to make sure that whatever
move we make is going to be maneuvering
the night or finding a night sacrifice
that works
and just for an example if we try and
sacrifice the night right away
this is an immediate draw there is no
way for the white king to
to pass this black pawn and the same
situation
all down the board no way to pass
through so
sacking the knight onto b4 is not going
to work
what other recommendations are coming
through the chat um
we're getting a recommendation to
sacrifice on g5
um very tempting but again even if we
can get our knight to h3 and sack on g5
the pawn takes and then once the black
king runs to the corner
it's just going to be a draw there's no
way for white's king to break through on
either side
and as soon as black captures the h pawn
because it's extended itself
it's just a draw great wolf has a
suggestion
uh first plan thinks they need to get
the knight to
a4 which means b2
so the way we solve this position is
actually in a few stages
i'm going to talk about a couple
different ideas and then actually walk
through those stages here
so first kind of like a visualization
or i guess planning type of strategy is
to imagine if that night were not on the
board
just imagine you took that knight picked
it right up and took it off
and then let's say you were playing bug
house or crazy house
and you had a knight in the pocket where
would you drop that knight on the board
and here the knight would make a lot of
sense on f5
this knight is going to attack the h6
pawn which is the base of the pawn chain
on the king side
and the only square that the black king
can control
um or i guess help protect h6
with the knight on f5 is on h7
the knight will control the g7 square
which means if we get the knight on f5
and the king is on h7 we can make a king
move in zigzwang black
black will have to step to the eighth
rank and then the knight can take on h6
and then the knight will just maneuver
back around and then the g5 pawn will
fall eventually
so that is going to be our winning plan
uh so now we need to think of ways to
get to
get to f5 um
let's see if we try from the white side
you have g3 and h4 g3 just doesn't work
the the f pawn will take and then once
you recapture there's no way to break
through pushing the f pawn won't help
but if the knight is on h4
then let's say pawn takes and if king
takes
you can push through with the pawns
after takes king takes
this rook pawn is going to be passed and
will promote
so now the problem is how do we get this
knight on h sorry
h4 is it even possible
so to to get to h4 from the kingside
um or white side you need to come from
g2
and to come to g2 you need to come from
e1 and to come to e1 you need to come
from c2
and to get to c2 you need to come from
a1 and there's no way to get to a1
so unfortunately that just isn't
possible we have to go through with
great wolf's plan
of maneuvering the knight to a4 and
seeing if we can come around
on black's side of the position to come
to f5
so very first move king to b2
we want to clear a path for our knight
where the knight can go to c1
e2 g1 h3
and then adjust itself by coming back on
f2
d1 b2 and a4
so that is stage one black's king is
just going to make shuffling moves
because
they have no counter play so i feel like
these moves shouldn't need too much
explanation
and in 10 moves we can get the knight to
a4
once we get the knight to a4 black has
to make a move
uh they can't go to b7 because we just
take on c5
which means their only move is king to
d6
and now where should our where should
our knight go from
here someone's asking why not king d2
instead of king b2
um so there's a couple ideas uh later in
the position which will make sense why
the king is over on the queen side
you could go to d2 um but later you
would have to just move the king over to
the queen side anyway
so i'll explain uh i'll explain why the
king is on the queen side in just a
second
where is our knight going
knight to b6 so knight to b6 is a good
move
and we need to see where it's going from
here uh and it's going to d5
and from d5 it actually has a way just
to get to
f5 just in two moves or coming to
g8 and then picking off the pawn that
way
so to stop those ideas
the black king needs to oscillate
between e7 and f6
so the king is going to be on e6 and f7
controlling these two squares that help
white's plan in the long run so king to
e6
knight to d5 and now king to f7 again
just stopping the knight from making any
progress towards the king side
so if if black is just going to shuffle
their king there we need to find a bit
more of an
active plan for white to
to break through so
unfortunately here knight to c3 is not
the solution
although we would all love to see it be
so
so i want to uh just kind of remind you
guys of the idea in the beginning of the
position
if the knight was on h4 and the king was
on h3
then that position if black took would
be winning
white would take back create an outside
passer and then promote
and if black's king tried to stop the
the passer
the white's king can go across the other
side of the board and promote
or sorry not promote just capture all
the blacks pawns and then push another
pawn to promote
so that idea does exist on the king side
but this idea also exists on the queen
side and this is why it's important the
king is on a2
instead of d2 so manny's trying to
suggest another knight reroute so
let's just go over that first knight b6
he wants
the knight to go to c8 and then e7
and then f5 or to d6 and f5 but the
problem is after
king 2 um e7 here no matter where the
knight goes
um the king will be able to control the
proper square so like if the knight
comes back to d5 just go to e6
if it goes to c8 then the king can go to
d7
so unfortunately knight b6 with the idea
of a different route to f5 isn't going
to work
in fact knight to b6 just isn't going to
work at all because
b6 is the square we came from if we go
back to b6 we're going to end up
repeating eventually
well okay i guess i just accidentally
showed it but the move here is knight to
c7
with the idea of sacrificing the knight
on a3
so the same idea that was on the king
side exists on the queen side
the king comes back over knight b5
king to d7 and knight a3 and now if
black takes king takes is going to be a
simple win
because of king c6 pawn b4 take
take push and then close opposition is
going to force the king away
king comes to d5 and it's impossible to
save e5
so if black takes it is a winning king
and pawn end game for white
black can't take so they just shuffle
the king
and now i ask how how does white proceed
from here
if we go back to b4 it's just going to
repeat what we've already been through
right we've already found out the knight
can't travel on the
black side of the board to get to f5 so
going back to b4
is going to be rather pointless
and manny has it if you don't capture
the knight on h3
then the knight actually just gets to go
to h4 and from the very beginning we
said that if the knight is on h4
it's going to win because there's
zugzwang here in this position there is
no zigzwang because
this b-pawn is not against the edge of
the board
so the knight makes its journey to h4
and again i feel like this is this is
self-explanatory
um for these moves no black can't do
anything there's no counter play
so all white needs to do is maneuver
their pieces to the king side
to be prepared for this sacrifice
and now that both sides have made it to
the king side knight h4 is playable
and now here uh black can't stop knight
to f5 which we've already discussed is a
win
for example king f6 knight f5
the king cannot protect the h6 pawn sad
story
it's going to fall the knight's going to
come back and then this
pawn can try and break through the
knights can maneuver around on the other
side again try and capture on c5 or e5
and again if they take then king takes
king moves over and now white creates
this passer
they sack upon temporarily to be able to
get
this sort of um position here where
black is in zugzwang
they can no longer protect their pawn so
they have to move away
white captures and now after king h7
stopping this pawn from moving forward
king to f5 e5 is falling
shortly followed by c5 falling and then
white
is going to push all of their pawns here
and unfortunately this plan for for
black with the knight
coming to uh f5 that one is unstoppable
so the best move for them here
is to take the knight there is no way
around it
and this is a positional plan that even
though the computer gives a winning
evaluation for whites
will not find the proper plan
so there you have it there's all our
puzzles for tonight you guys are now
smarter than a computer
i'm expecting everyone to go out and
beat stockfish with crazy tactics
if you do send the games in we might get
caleb to go over them for
game review but i want to thank
everybody for coming in
for the tactics time i want to thank
manny and great wolf especially they
stuck around for the openings to explain
lecter on youtube as well i want to wish
everyone a good night
and we will see you next time
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club